what if we did a podcast what if we
lined up some of the world's top
thinkers in science astronomy technology
academia and futurism and asked them to
ponder some of the most popular what if
videos of all time this is what if
discussed what if we lived fifty years
into the future the future is neutral
it's gonna be whatever we want it to be
and whatever we make of it sometime very
very soon as we get better at this we're
going to be able to create virtual
worlds that are more fun and more
meaningful than regular reality what if
we are living in a simulation even if
the simulation hypothesis is true there
is that the question of what that would
entail if anything should you live your
life differently if you knew for sure
you were in simulation or the things you
should do or not do what if you fell
into a pool of liquid nitrogen
it's a really interesting question what
would happen to you because when you
fall into it you would start to freeze
and you'd feel all this this these
needles and pins all over your body and
at the same time you'd be under a liquid
like being underwater so you'd be
drowning what if we became cyborgs I
define myself as a cyborg because I am a
cybernetic organism biologically I am
merged with technology of all these
cybernetics many people think we are
against God we're not against God we're
not going against our bodies we are
collaborating with God whatever we
discovered alien life
you haven't hardly begun to look and how
much have we searched and the answer is
one glass of water out of all the
Earth's oceans
what if we're living in a Galactic Zoo I
think when we imagine aliens it's
natural to project our greatest fears
and our deepest desires out there
realistically I don't think we'll get
either about but maybe what we most get
is a chance to hold a mirror up to
ourselves what if half of the Earth's
population was suddenly wiped out 25
years ago the world scientists warning
the humanity and the world scientists
statement on population all said if you
keep growing you're screwed and nobody
pays any attention everybody is hooked
on growth what if I think we're going to
be returning to the moon certainly
within the next five years that would be
Tuesday we possess the technology to go
back and have a settlement within 10
years space has always been there
alongside dinosaurs the thing that
captivates us when we're 5 years old and
we never quite give it up it's still
captivating it still inspires many many
questions I have an older brother who
got me into everything I'm into you
today and I remember lying there with
him looking up at the stars and it
planted the notion in my mind that there
could be life out there too a 5 or 6
year old me
this was this was a game changer join
hosts Teddy Wilson and Richard garner as
they take a deeper dive into some of
your favorite what-if videos with some
of the foremost thought leaders on the
planet on what if discussed listen and
what if show.com forward slash podcast
or wherever you listen and subscribe to
podcasts